[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la influencia que puede tener la guerra
de ucrania en las elecciones que va a
celebrar francia ya en menos de un mes
para ello me acompañan en este estudio
gabriela bravo periodista en radio
cooperativa de chile bienvenida gabriela
mucho gusto rafael plus periodista en el
diario la opinión aquí en francia
bienvenido a rafael gracias build y así
mi compañera en el servicio brasileño de
radio francia internacional paloma varón
bienvenida mucho de carache ucrania
marca las cartas de las presidenciales
en francia hoy nuestro asunto en primera
plana
que haya menos de un mes para las
elecciones presidenciales en francia
pero la campaña ha quedado eclipsada por
la guerra en ucrania mientras parece que
makro no puede salir beneficiado de su
posición presidencial los candidatos de
la extrema derecha hace muro y le print
y el izquierdista melanson se enfrentan
ahora a su controvertida relación
computing según todos los sondeos la
duda está instalada en quien se
clasificará para la segunda vuelta para
disputar la presidencia macrón en una
campaña en la que las relaciones con
putin la energía o el aumento brutal del
precio del carburante toman relevancia
para definir el próximo inquilino del
elíseo ucrania marca el paso en las
presidenciales como lo muestran también
la por las estas portadas de la prensa
francesa diario le figaro califica esta
campaña como de campaña impedida debido
a la guerra de ucrania y dice que un 79
por ciento de los franceses piensa ya
que saldrá reelegido macrón piensa no
que quiera le parisian tras la ofensiva
de putin la onda del shock llega a
francia con temas como la energía o la
seguridad que se instalan en esta
campaña y también este artículo de
lemont que explica cómo la guerra sitúa
al jefe del estado en una posición
singular
ventaja y fragiliza al resto de
candidatos bueno pues a menos de un mes
de las presidenciales gabriela no se
sabría qué hablar de una campaña
errática impedida eclipsada qué
objetivos le pondrían al nombre de lo
que estamos viviendo yo le diría una
campaña eclipsada porque la campaña está
pero no ha podido surgir es decir todo
el mundo se ha preparado hemos visto los
candidatos de extrema derecha
izquierdistas que hace ya un momento que
empezaron sus campañas sin embargo una
vez que quisieron dar este impulso que
es las últimas semanas hemos visto que
ha llegado esta noticia que es la guerra
de ucrania y todos los medios de
comunicación se han centrado en eso en
esta en este tiempo en estas últimas
semanas notábamos un aire así como está
el aire de navidad el aire de campaña
presidencial que no se ha podido
desarrollar en este último tiempo debido
a que la contingencia es tan importante
ya que se habla de como una posible
tercera guerra mundial hay que hay que
tomar en cuenta que es un es una
contingencia muy compleja esto ha
impedido de que se pueda hacer una
elección presidencial normal a cabalidad
rafael no sé si esto podría ser la
campaña más anómala de la quinta
república que en francia la es primero
porque antes de la guerra en ucrania
teníamos la pandemia y la pandemia
durante muchos meses antes de navidad' y
a partir del mes de enero
pues casi también tenía el mismo efecto
que la guerra en ucrania o sea que lo
tapaba todo y entonces incluso dentro de
los equipos de campaña mucha gente decía
pues esperemos porque a partir del mes
de sabemos que en primavera
el hobbit pues tenía esa tendencia a
desaparecer pero hacerse un poco más
fácil de vivir las restricciones pues ya
hemos visto que ya no están y aún así
con la guerra pues vemos que hemos
pasado esa etapa con una campaña
dominada por la pandemia a una campaña
dominada por la guerra en la que pues
hay muy poco espacio para el debate
porque estamos todos claro con el
enfoque hacia lo que pasa en el este
entonces desde luego quedan tres semanas
y podemos decir ahora ya de manera casi
cierta de qué es la compañía
presidencial más rara de la historia de
la quinta república eso sí paloma yo
diría que es una campaña aquí y empezó y
ya terminó por eso porque salimos de la
pandemia y entramos en la guerra no nos
salimos claro no no se acabó pero con el
relajamiento de las medidas y todo eso
cuando finalmente pensábamos que íbamos
a respirar un poco
es eso es la guerra y todo lo que me
parece gracioso y gracioso de esta
campaña es que en 2017 cuando ma jin le
pen fue a rusia él fue cuatro veces a
rusia para pedir financiamiento de
campaña y tenía una amistad con putin el
miedo de los franceses era la influencia
de poder en las elecciones
completa porque
podríamos decir que macro gabriel es el
gran beneficiado de esta situación
anómala por su posición de interlocutor
incansable o por esa teoría que dice que
en momentos de crisis llegamos dos
clicks consecutivas la sanitaria y la de
la guerra en ucrania la opinión pública
se repliega y para apoyar a sus
dirigentes es decir se arman filas
detrás y por supuesto o sea lo que aquí
en francia se llama el efecto bandera el
efecto es decir todos nos cuadramos
detrás de la nuestra nación en este
momento el presidente macro no
representa la nación francesa no es algo
sumamente ambiguo porque es candidato a
la reelección pero al mismo tiempo es
presidente de la república francesa y al
mismo tiempo es presidente de la unión
europea entonces es una figura que se ha
visto en todos los medios es un
interlocutor privilegiado
para hablar con rusia entonces su figura
hay que ver lo que ha pasado en las
encuestas de opinión él ha subido entre
6 a 8 puntos desde el inicio de la
guerra entre rusia y ucrania es es pero
es enorme porque si bien manuel macrón
el candidato a la presidencia iba
encabezando las encuestas esto lo ha
separado completamente de todos sus
opositores y como veíamos en las
portadas de los diarios la gente la
mayoría de los franceses piensa que él
ya está en segunda vuelta
rafael tenemos el tema de la guerra de
ucrania grande mí mismo inunda todos los
medios de comunicación y también la
oposición es muy complicado hacer
oposición con este con este asunto es
muy complicado desmarcarse de la
posición de una crítica a putin como que
pueden hacer que salidas hay que
espacios hay para el resto de candidatos
pero es imposible por lo que es esa
guerra porque esa guerra es una guerra
de agresión es una innovación ilegal de
grana y así es
incluso los políticos franceses que
tenían cierta admiración hacia putin no
se pueden permitir otra observación que
la constatación de lo que es esa guerra
luego pues claro como decía gabriel a lo
del efecto bandera
como nosotros en europa en el western y
el mundo occidental en general no es que
seamos enemigos de putin pero claro en
la confrontación
diplomática política acerca de este
cumplido pues estamos en un bando
estamos en un campo entonces es muy
difícil para la oposición criticar al
presidente sin dar la impresión de
apoyar al no quiero decir enemigo porque
ya no estamos en estas pero me entendéis
no al otro bando al otro campo entonces
claro
la dificultad está en
tener esa postura presidencial
pareciendo presidente por el claro sus
candidatos quieren ser presidente o
presentar la república tonces tienen que
parecer un poco serio un poco
pues listo para el cargo y al mismo
tiempo puedes encontrar los huecos de
críticas estamos complicados de
encontrar ese es el matiz sobre todo en
esta primera etapa en que todavía
estamos en la consternación y esto se le
suma el historial pasado de otros
candidatos en liza computing empecemos
analizando la extrema derecha porque lo
documenta antes paloma el epen ha
intentado desligarse y ha tenido
palabras de apoyo a la acogida de
refugiados y zemour intenta mostrarse
como el más radical no sé si esto ya lo
está pagando fémur
estamos hablando de la extrema derecha y
las relaciones que puedan tener con
computing creo que sí que ya está
pagando porque después que empezó la
guerra aseguró no no no para de bajar en
las encuestas esperando a ser un poco de
putin francés sí claro tiene una
tendencia un poco totalitarista y deja
claro eso bueno claro que después que
vio que eso no era bueno para su
electorado para los franceses en general
ha intentado cambiar un poco su discurso
de pero ayer por ejemplo estaba en la
televisión
y anexado y ya he quitado ha dicho que
era un criminal de guerra como bay tiene
otros ya han dicho y de muse no quiso
decir eso para ello la situación es es
tremenda porque si miramos los sondeos
macro 'nba primero pero es que los tres
siguientes tanto de extrema derecha
como izquierdista melanson tienen
relaciones muy complicadas con putin
este tema es muy complicado para ellos y
es sumamente complicado porque por un
lado está al distinto grado por supuesto
logrado porque le pen ha hecho cuatro
viajes creamos es distinto del ganado
pero bueno pero aquí
entre estavayer esta rencilla de las
personas que tienen relaciones complejas
computing yo creo que smart independent
que han sacado la mejor parte porque
ellas sin decir nada sin
mostrándose un poquito más benévola que
es hemos ha logrado subir en las
encuestas de opinión es ella quien ella
habla lo menos posible de ese tema y
sigue aumentando sus probabilidades de
votantes en cambio hacemos como tiene
una postura mucho más
más directa más fuerte sobre el tema y
hay que decir que si uno mira hacia
atrás lo que él habla él es un admirador
real de vladimir putin se encuentra
la frase perdón a gabriela del fémur en
2018 que llegó a decir de putin le
admiro por haber cogido un país que era
un imperio que podría haber sido una
gran potencia intentar levantarlo es
decir ahí muestra como él
él era hacer lo mismo con francis es
exactamente entonces esto le ha jugado
muy mal hacemos por otro lado está jean
luc mélenchon que ha
reprochado muchas veces digamos su
tibieza con autócratas como justamente
que no llegó pues él se le reclama que
el noa noa criticado de frente sin
embargo lo que muestran también los
sondeos de opinión es que esto no ha
afectado en una dinámica digamos que él
sigue creciendo poco a poco lentamente
pero esto no le ha tocado
como si como hemos visto que hacemos que
el ha bajado raudamente en las encuestas
de opinión rafael yo creo que podemos
distinguir dos maneras de no de apoyar a
putin pero tomás dos maneras de
y explicar o justificar lo que hace en
francia la ultraderecha lo admira porque
es un hombre fuerte y está con esa idea
de que el país necesita un puño de
hierro no es un líder que no vacila en
tomar decisiones difíciles desde la
izquierda o desde la ultraizquierda
digamos el enfoque es distinto es se ve
bueno lo que quería comentar también que
la ultraderecha ve a putin como el
escudo del occidente cristiano o frente
a la inversión musulmana que
no estoy carl icahn turca educar y
capturando mucho desde la izquierda es
más como el enfoque de
instituciones como la otra ven a putin
como un escudo pero si no como el
contrapeso a la influencia de la otan y
de eeuu en europa del este y están en un
poco más en una posición de
equidistantes no como ni rusia ni eeuu
lo que pasa que sabes qué distancia en
una situación de invasión es muy
complicada más claro claro por eso a
menos bueno se acostó tres comunicados
de prensa pero al final denunció de
manera muy clara a la guerra y ahora
está hablando está poniendo a rusia en
la postura del agresor
me parece que algo inteligente es que el
saco esto no alineado
no somos neutros es decir no es que no
nos interese pero no estamos alineados
yo creo que eso se ha puesto como un
escudo frente a estos ataques que le
llegan de bueno decídete cuál es tu
postura estás por él es no no no estamos
alineados y esto le ha permitido zafar
un poco y afirmó una pequeña pausa y en
unos instantes continuamos aquí hablando
de la influencia de buscar en las
elecciones francesas en primera plana
hasta ahora
[Música]
de bienvenidos a la noticia de france
amargas y café
wagner
casi 99 millones de ustedes nos siguen
cada semana en france 24 su cromo
gracias yo con fermín min chivas muchas
gracias su granada deje de gentes con
sean penn que me significa
liberté égalité actual y t
seguimos aquí en primera plana esta
semana analizando la influencia que
tiene la guerra de ucrania y voy a decir
en la campaña electoral francesa pero ya
me han dicho nuestros invitados que
bueno que campaña eclipsada que no
podemos hablar de campaña o de campaña
anómala pero en cualquier caso vamos a
seguir hablando de ello con rafael plus
gabriela bravo y paloma varón de todo lo
que acarrea la guerra de ucrania en
cuanto a debates derivados es decir
tenemos tres semanas por delante de
campaña electoral pero ya no tenemos la
agenda de temas que teníamos antes ni
siquiera la crisis ya ni tarja ahora de
lo que hagamos es de precios de las
energías de gestión de la crisis de
refugiados de soberanía europea de
defensa de carburantes de ciberataques
que cuestiones creen que van a interesar
más a los franceses en lo que queda de
campaña paloma creo aquí mismo antes de
esta guerra ya era la que son
predominante de esta elección el poder
de poder adquisitivo esto es el más
importante de los franceses hoy son más
preocupados con el precio de cómo cuándo
van a supermercado o por el tanque de
gasolina entonces si hay digamos
factores que influyen en ese poder
adquisitivo por ejemplo las materias
primas que salen como en los productos
por ejemplo el precio de los carburantes
decir este asunto también está ahora
modificado por la coyuntura ya teníamos
una inflación de 3% sin la guerra ahora
la previsión es que llegue a 5% entonces
está peor sin sillas ya sabíamos que era
un tema preponderante el poder
adquisitivo ahora estaba más y más
importante y yo creo que más chrome pero
como también marx independizó
vieron eso que eso es importante
entonces claro hay que condenar putin
etcétera pero hay que pensar en el bolso
francés van a agotar con eso en la
cabeza
porque por ejemplo guerra en ucrania
seguimos importando gas de rusia o no si
lo detenemos que hacemos con la subida
de precios montamos un mecanismo de
solidaridad dentro del unión europea
para compartir un poco la carga de luz
estos son cuestión temas bastante
importantes tú decías lo de la cereales
el problema el precio del pan que va a
subir que hacemos entonces son
cuestiones muy muy concretas muy claras
que están llegando ahora mismo en la
campaña logró también la soberanía
nacional que es un tema que se ocupa
mucho
a la derecha
nos hemos puesto ahora los franceses se
han puesto a pensar realmente que la
soberanía no es a lo mejor solamente un
tema de extrema derecha sino que sí que
vamos a hacer si no tenemos gas la
guerra de ucrania estaba vista como una
guerra como una agresión pero también
como la primera preocupación es el poder
adquisitivo como esta guerra va a
influir en nuestro poder adquisitivo
vamos y el gas va a subir la bencina va
a subir es la comida va a subir entonces
si bien la primera preocupación es el
poder adquisitivo esta guerra está
ligada íntima íntimamente a este poder
adquisitivo antes antes de la guerra
entre rusia y ucrania las preocupaciones
estaban entre el poder adquisitivo salud
y medio ambiente ahora vemos que el
medio ambiente ahora mismo en francia
pero pasado completamente desapercibido
y a los candidatos que les funcionaba
hablar de este tema ha quedado
completamente relegado la energía
nuclear como parte al menos de la
solución a la soberanía energética es
también cuestión derivada de ucrania con
candidatos en posiciones muy distintas
que ya estaban definidas antes de la
guerra tienen la sensación de que un
enfoque mixto que comprende a la energía
nuclear en parte ahora mismo ya es
mayoritario y asumido por la sociedad
francesa de esta situación de la guerra
esto ha cambiado también porque antes
cuando marcelo la posición digamos
también de macro no si es de una
soberanía energética que ahora es la
cosa más importante entonces cuando los
macro empezó su quinquenio en 2017
querían cerrar las usinas nucleares y
eso era un discurso un poco de izquierda
pero también de una la mayoría de los
franceses era contra nuclear como 50 y
51 por ciento un poco la mayoría del pp
ahora ya son por el nuclear por eso por
esa soberanía nuclear digamos que el
presi de macrón anunció en su programa
antes de la guerra de ucrania la
activación creo que eran seis nuevos
reactores nucleares hubo críticas hacia
macro pero la nueva coyuntura ha hecho
que el otro día presentada de nuevo su
programa y ya esas críticas se han
evaporado en parte primero hay que
subrayar que sin malcolm decidió
y relanzar el programa nuclear en
francia lo hizo con pretextos con
argumentos climáticos diciendo que es
una energía que no produce
como se dice gases que es más limpia que
las fósiles encuentran no hay emisiones
de gases de gases y ahora se añade pues
otro argumento que es que está bien para
la
independencia energética no sólo de
francia haciendo de todo llevado a la
coyuntura es un argumento muy de peso
claro pero también hay que decir que en
francia hay una obsesión nuclear no
sobre los políticos sino del sector
industrial y de la opinión pública en
general porque claro producimos yo creo
que el 75 o el 80 por ciento de la
electricidad en francia viene de la
energía nuclear cuesta mucha infancia
ponerse en contra de esa energía porque
fue una bueno es una energía con la que
llevamos ya casi 40 o 50 años y de hecho
sólo dos candidatos el ecologista
aislado y el inicialista menos son
proponen la salida del nuclear y aún así
la proponen dentro de 25 ó 30 años
porque es una buena transformación que
aún si la empresa moss pues va a tardar
años en hacerse es que incluso existe lo
contrario otros países de la unión
europea más dependientes
y energía de la energía rusa ahora miran
el modelo de francia dicen bueno es que
a lo mejor nos tenemos que abrir esa
portal nuclear es decir e incluso se
puede esta guerra puede dar el efecto
contrario si es que bueno es que esto ha
venido a barajar las cartas digamos que
esta campaña se iba debería haberse
desarrollado
con la izquierda que propone por ejemplo
salida del nuclear a la gente que le
gusta la derecha el nuclear pero ahora
todo el mundo ha tenido que volver a
revisar su copia porque ya estamos este
es este tema ahora está implicado como
quienes están por rusia quienes no
quienes así no salimos vamos a tener que
depender todavía de la energía rusa es
decir vamos a tener que pactar vamos a
tener que aceptar ciertas condiciones
estamos en que cuando independientes y
no sólo no sólo francia porque aquí uno
de los países que más es alemania quien
depende más si es el país que más
depende del gas ruso a alemania austria
es todavía tienen porcentajes de 80 por
ciento francia se puede permitir
a ciertas leyes momentos que se lo puede
permitir gracias a esa energía nuclear
la incógnita estas alturas más que saber
bueno macro se sale primero todos los
sondeos es más bien quién va a colarse
en la segunda vuelta o en el balotaje
junto a manuel macro cómo cambiarían los
escenarios les pregunto rafael o palomas
si fueran lepén o melanson como cambiar
y en ese escenario de la segunda vuelta
como lo cree
sería la repetición de la vuelta del
2017 y yo creo que este pues sería un
poco una
pérdida para la democracia pero como es
un debate que ya hemos tenido yo creo
que para es para mucha gente la
perspectiva de otro enfrentamiento entre
el opening manco no es algo que te lleva
a ir a las urnas porque en cambio lo de
menos un sí es verdad que podría
volvernos a un enfrentamiento más
clásico izquierda contra derecha
yo creo que hablaríamos más de temas
como las pensiones de temas más
económicos seguro de la guerra de
ucrania pero yo creo que un
enfrentamiento entre menos
me podría interesar más a los votantes
en cualquier caso cualquier candidato
que llega a la segunda vuelta y no sé si
están de acuerdo va a tener difícil
confrontar con macro en la cuestión de
ucrania si no quiere ser percibido como
un opositor en momentos altamente
sensibles algo que la opinión pública
seguramente castigaría qué estrategia
entonces podría tomar ese candidato que
se enfrente a macro en la segunda vuelta
yo creo que el magic más difícil para
los dos es hacer que la gente va a votar
porque en las regionales del año pasado
por ejemplo hubo 166 por ciento de
abstención entonces este año como 79%
los franceses creen que macro está de la
base reelecto porque ir a votar para sin
diferencias de macrón creo que es
siempre el poder adquisitivo es eso es
decir como
en el bolsillo del francés como pueda
cambiar qué van a hacer macro ha dicho
un cheque para energía cheque para
inflación pero esos son son ayudas
puntuales cómo hacer eso para todos los
días me gustaría decir que la diferencia
que puede haber entre un match macrón
lepén en esta en esta oportunidad es que
macro no eran nuevos y él era disruptivo
ahora propone continuidad dentro del de
una derecha y mucha gente de izquierda
votó por él en contra de marín le pen y
esto que se llama el bagaje está esta
barrera contra el extrema derecha yo
creo que se ha ido desmoronando poco a
poco y ese es el gran tema de emanuel
macro porque él ya está casi en segunda
vuelta ahora hay que ver cómo logra
hacer todos él hizo todo contra lepén o
sea yo soy la única persona que la puede
frenar y ahora esto se va desmigajado
poco a poco y le puede jugar muy en
contra de manuel macro y lo que cambió
también de
2017 para hoy es que hoy marine le pen
ha hecho una de diabolización de su
partido entonces tiene posiciones que
podían ser de la derecha tradicional
como dos en gurb ha tomado este espacio
de la ultraderecha y me imagino hoy día
defiende cosas que son mismo por lo
social
y todo eso
no para la inmigración pero para
el casamiento homosexual y otras cosas y
entonces eso cambio también yo creo que
la izquierda no va a algunos quieren
anti
ultraderecha nos van a votar nos va a
hacer esa frente amplia amplia contra
otras formas de todos los candidatos son
están admiración de las consecuencias
económicas y sociales que tendrá la
guerra de ucrania en francia y en europa
pero no sé si la opinión pública
francesa
está sensibilizada de conciencia del
tema o si nos están diciendo la gravedad
de lo que se puede venirse yo creo que
no y por ejemplo si nos fijamos en las
encuestas vemos por ejemplo que el mayor
miedo ahora es la guerra nuclear parece
un poco absurdo pero como hubo amenazas
y que tampoco es un escenario en un
guión que ahora parece de tan
descalabrado absoluto como lo parecía
antes
pero tiene razón yo creo que más que
guerra nuclear lo que nos va a impactar
van a ser las consecuencias por el claro
las sanciones económicas que tomamos en
contra de ucrania rusia también nos van
a afectar que las asumimos luego en el
otro debate pero lo que se nos viene el
impacto económico que va a pasar con los
sectores que estaban muy ligados con
rusia las importaciones de ucrania
estamos hablando de inclusión social
como por ejemplo la acogida de
refugiados la ola solidaria es muy
cálida al principio
veremos cuando el tiempo pase y el foco
no esté no creo que vaya a ser un tema
muy grande porque vemos que los
refugiados la mayor parte se concentra
en polonia y vamos a tener
se me acaba el tiempo muchísimas gracias
a los tres ha sido un placer estar con
ustedes y a todos ustedes les esperamos
aquí la próxima semana en primera plana
gracias
[Música]